قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي دانيال
هكاري ان الجيش يجري تعديلات على انتشاره
في قطاع غزه حيث يتوقع حربا طويله ضد حركه
حماس تمتد طوال العام الجديد باكمله واضاف
في افادته اليوميه ان الجيش سينفذ ما وصفه
باداره ذكيه للقوات في غزه مما يسمح لجنود
الاحتياط بالعوده الى ديارهم للمساعده في
انعاش الاقتصاد والسماح لافراد قوات الجيش
الدائمه بالتدريب ليصبحوا
قاده نعمل على تعديل اساليب القتال لكل
منطقه في غزه وكذلك القوات اللازمه لتنفيذ
المهمه بافضل طريقه ممكنه ولكل منطقه
خصائص واحتياجات تشغيليه مختلفه الليله
سيبدا عام
2024 اهدف الحرب تتطلب قتالا طويلا ونحن
مستعدون وفقا لذلك ومستمرون في تدريب
الضباط والقاده بعد خبرتهم في القتال
يعودون الى التدريب وسينضم الى صف قاده
الجيش عند انتهائهم بعض جنود الاحتياط
سيعودون الى عائلاتهم وسيعملون هذا
الاسبوع سيؤدي ذلك الى ارتياح كبير
للاقتصاد وسيسمح لهم باكتساب القوه
للعمليات في العام المقبل وسيستمر القتال
وسنحتاج اليهم تهدف هذه التعديلات الى
ضمان التخطيط والاستعدادات للعام الجديد
يحتاج الجيش الاسرائيلي الى التخطيط
للمستقبل من منطلق ادراك انه ستكون هناك
حاجه الينا للقيام بمهام اضافيه ومواصله
القتال خلال هذا العام
باكمله